l'aéroport du lamentin et ses milliers
de passagers depuis 2007 le lieu porte
le nom d'aimé césaire cet espace est sa
pièce maîtresse rendent hommage à
l'homme
ce buste a été inauguré en 2013 long de
l'année de commémoration de sa naissance
en martinique c'est donc le premier
contact avec aimé césaire
l'homme qui le sont vivants avait fini
par accepter cet honneur rejaillit
simplement qu'elle n'avait aucune
ambition de sergent et je suis chez au
prix est touchée fait tout direction
fort de france sur la façade de
l'actuelle mairie cet immense portrait
rappelle le personnage à une centaine de
mètres il y a le théâtre et à l'étagé un
espace muséal labellisé maisons des
illustres 1 depuis avril dernier c'était
le dernier bureau occupé par aimé
césaire
ici chaque détail a été pensé dès l
annonce du décès d'aimé césaire en 2008
l'ouverture de son bureau au public a
été affiché comme une priorité
ces murs ont en effet été témoin de
toutes ces années à la tête de la ville
et plus encore car la construction du
nouvel hôtel de ville aimé césaire
conserver ici un lieu de travail où il
recevait ses interlocuteurs du monde
entier quittons ce lieu et faisons une
courte halte au collège qui porte son
nom
il est situé dans le quartier des terres
sainville un autre collège de
basse-pointe porte également le nom
d'aimé césaire
dans ce quartier il y a le sermac pure
création du maire de fort de france
le sermac et son incontournable festival
créé dans les années soixante dix autres
lieux et pas des moindres la maison
d'aimé césaire situé route de redoute
une maison qui fait l'objet d'un travail
d'inventaire depuis quelques mois
klinsi nos graphiques et d'être mis en
place
car cela qu'un en train de travailler
justement avec l'architecte du
patrimoine qui est en quête l'équipe été
choisie est sélectionné pour tout une
cellule qui travaillent dessus pour que
tout soit en lien en même temps et
surtout respecte et continue
extension d'un penser les mais césaire
dernière halte à fort-de-france le
cimetière de la joyau c'est ici que
repose aimé césaire devenu chaque année
un lieu de pèlerinage à la date
anniversaire de sa mort enfin direction
basse pointe à 57km le fort de france
dans sa commune de naissance et la
bêtise de dire quand j'ai pas beaucoup
habité ma couette du basket m'a toujours
habité ce me rappelle qu'il est né et a
vécu ici ses premières années